SERIOUS SITUATION.
PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS, PEOPLE ARE
PANICKED.
BEFORE LONG, YES, WE’LL BE BACK.
WE’LL BE STRONGER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE HAVE FACED PANDEMICS BEFORE
AND WHEN WE HAVE, WHAT HAS
HAPPENED?
WE FIND WAYS.
WE ALWAYS DO.
JOINING US NOW, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
FIRST OF ALL, YOUR OVERALL
REACTION, IT’S VERY HARD, I
GUESS, EVERYTHING FOR THE NEXT
237 DAYS, WILL BE VIEWED THROUGH
THE PRISM OF POLITICS IN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT’S THE NATURE OF POLITICS.
THIS SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT’S
NOT POLITICAL BUT IT HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED.
LET’S BE HONEST.
NO PRESIDENT EVER ACTED FASTER.
THE PRESIDENT WAS CRITICIZED FOR
THE TRAVEL BAN, CRITICIZED FOR
THE QUARANTINED.
CRITICIZED, NO MATTER WHAT HE
DID ON THIS PARTICULAR THING,
IMMEDIATELY GAVE US $8.3 MILLION
TO SET UP THE TASK FORCE.
I GAVE A RUNDOWN, A TIMELINE,
AND HE’S STILL GETTING HIT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO PLAY THE
CRITICISM GAME, ALMOST EVERY
DEMOCRAT KIM OUT HARD AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL FROM CHINA.
THE STRONGEST DECISION HE’S
MADE, THE MOST IMPORTANT
DECISION, WAS TO ACT EARLY WHEN
HE SAW WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
CHINA.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID TONIGHT,
IT’S ABOUT US AS A NATION, NOT
MY PARTY, IT’S ABOUT ALL OF US.
SO HE GAVE AN ECONOMIC VACCINE.
IF WE WILL FOLLOW HIS LEAD, I’M
NOT SO SURE ABOUT THE PAYROLL
TAX YET BUT EVERYTHING ELSE HE
SAID MADE SENSE TO ME TO
STABILIZE THE ECONOMY AND
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
THE PRESIDENT WAS INCREDIBLY
PRESIDENTIAL TONIGHT.
HE WAS REASSURING.
HE’S DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN, IN
MY VIEW TO STOP THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS.
WE’RE TAKING IT SERIOUS BUT
WE’RE NOT GOING TO GO CRAZY.
>> SEAN: ALL RIGHT.
LETS GO THROUGH WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING
TONIGHT.
HE’LL ALWAYS PUT THE WELL-BEING
OF THE PEOPLE FIRST.
NO NATION IS BETTER PREPARED
THAN THE U.S.
WE’RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
PUT POLITICS ASIDE, WHICH WOULD
BE GOOD FOR ONCE.
HE PUT THE TRAVEL BAN INTO PLACE
FOR EUROPE FOR 30 DAYS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE UK.
EMERGENCY ACTIONS FOR PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR BUSINESSES
DIRECTLY IMPACTED.
I GUESS THE CREWS INDUSTRY, THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, AND WORKERS,
BY THE WAY, HOURLY PAID WORKERS
SO THEY WON’T LOSE THEIR JOBS
AND WILL HAVE SOME FINANCIAL
RELIEF IF THEY HAVE TO STAY OUT
FOR CAUTION.
ANYTHING ELSE HE SHOULD BE DOING
IN YOUR VIEW?
>> I CAN’T THINK OF ANYTHING.
I KNOW THIS.
IF PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD GIVEN
THIS SAME SPEECH, THEY WOULD BE
APPLAUDING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
FOR DECISIVE LEADERSHIP, CLEAR
EYED VIEW OF THE PROBLEM, TAKING
ACTION, PREVENTATIVE ACTION.
TRYING TO BRING ABOUT ECONOMIC
STABILITY BEFORE IT GETS WORSE.
TRYING TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS.
I HOPE THAT EVERYBODY LISTENING
TONIGHT SAW A PRESIDENT WHO WAS
IN COMMAND OF THE ISSUE, IN
CHARGE, READY TO DO WHATEVER IS
NECESSARY TO STABILIZE THE
ECONOMY, AND PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WOULD JUST SAY THIS OF ALL THE
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD WE’RE THE
STRONGEST, AND OF ALL THE PLACES
IN THE WORLD TO PROVIDE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE AMERICA IS THE
PREMIER SPOT ON THE PLANET AND
WE’RE GOING TO STAY THAT WAY.
>> SEAN: LET’S TALK ABOUT, THERE
IS A NEED FOR SOME PROSPECTIVE.
I’VE BEEN TRYING TO GET IT.
THIS IS 2009-2010.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT POLITICS, BUT
12,000 AMERICANS DIED, 20,000
CONTRACTED THE DISEASE.
THERE WAS NEVER A TRAVEL BAN.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY TYPE OF
QUARANTINE PUT INTO PLACE.
THERE WAS NOT THIS LEVEL OF
ALARMISM, EVEN THE MARKETS
DIDN’T REACT THIS PARTICULAR
WAY.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A PRESIDENT
INSTINCTIVELY PUT A BAN IN PLACE
AND TAKE A LOT OF HEAT FOR IT.
WHY, IF THE FLU, PURE NUMBERS,
MUCH MORE DANGEROUS, WHY DO YOU
THINK THERE IS THIS REACTION
THAT WE SEE EVERYWHERE, WHICH
WE -- WE’VE GOT TO TAKE
EVERYTHING SERIOUSLY.
I WANT A CURE FOR CANCER AND
HEART DISEASE, FOR THE FLU, FOR
THE COMMON COLD AND FOR CORONA.
OF COURSE WE’VE GOT TO BE
CAREFUL.
>> I THINK THE EXOTIC NATURE OF
IT.
IT CAME OUT OF CHINA, LEFT
FIELD, NOBODY UNDERSTANDS
EXACTLY WHAT IT’S ALL ABOUT YET.
CORONAVIRUS CASE IS LIKE AN
AIRPLANE CRASH.
THE FLU IS LIKE A CAR WRECK.
WE HAVE A LOT OF CAR WRECKS.
PEOPLE DIE IN CAR WRECKS BUT IT
DOESN’T GET MUCH COVERAGE.
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY GETS
INFECTED WITH THE CORONAVIRUS,
THAT’S THE WAY THE MEDIA HAS
TREATED THIS.
THEY HAVE TREATED IT LIKE A
SERIES OF AIRPLANE CRASHES AND
ALL I CAN SAY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT, IF YOU’VE GOT A
BETTER IDEA COME FORWARD.
I HOPE WHAT YOU’LL DO IS NOT
SIGN IT OFF AS SOME DEMOCRATIC
PACKAGE COMING OUT OF THE HOUSE
TOMORROW, THAT WON’T GROW THE
ECONOMY BUT WILL GROW THE SIZE
OF THE GOVERNMENT.
WE DON’T NEED ECONOMIC STIMULUS
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE NEED ECONOMIC STIMULUS FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND THEY
ARE GOING TO WANT TO GROW
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO DO IS HELP
THE ECONOMY.
>> SEAN: AND I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT THING.
NOW, THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
I MEAN, BRINGING ALL THESE
BANKERS IN, WALL STREET GUYS IN,
I THINK -- LISTEN, WE’VE HAD THE
GREATEST ECONOMIC GROWTH WE’VE
HAD.
WE SEE THE JITTERY MARKETS
REACTING DAY BY DAY TO WHAT’S
GOING ON.
THE ADDED FACTOR OF AN OIL
BATTLE, IF YOU WILL, BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THE SAUDIS AND OPEC.
THAT DOES NOT HELP THINGS BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY WE’VE HAD
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC GROWTH.
THE QUESTION IS, IF WE CAN KEEP
THESE NUMBERS LOW, LOCAL CITIES,
LOCAL STATES, MUNICIPALITIES
DOING THEIR THING, SCHOOLS
CLOSING AS THEY DEEM NECESSARY,
PEOPLE TAKING PRECAUTIONS THAT
THEY CAN TAKE, AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WHAT WE HAVE IS A VIRUS
THAT’S VERY SCARY, LIKE EVERY
OTHER VIRUS, BUT IT IS UNLIKE
H-1-N-1, THIS SEEMS TO BE
PUTTING AT RISK ONLY THE ELDERLY
WITH UNDERLYING HEALTH ISSUES
AND SOME TYPE OF IMMUNE
DISORDERS, HOW DO YOU INTERPRET
THAT DATA?
HE’S ASKING BANKS TO BE
INVOLVED.
WE WANT TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION CAN LOAN TO
PEOPLE TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET.
LOOK AT SEE WHAT DEMOCRATS WILL
DO TOMORROW.
I THINK THEY WILL GRO
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
THEY HAVEN’T TALKED TO ANYBODY
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR ABOUT WHAT
WE CAN DO TO STABILIZE THE
ECONOMY.
THEIR REACTION UNFORTUNATELY IS
GOING TO BE TO GROW THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT’S ACTION IS TO TRY
TO CREATE A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
SECTOR TO STABILIZE THE ECONOMY
AND HE REALIZES MORE THAN ANY
PRESIDENT IN MY LIFETIME IS THE
STRENGTH OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY